il y a 400000 ans un nouvel homme voit
le jour il est le premier représentant
d'une famille
extraordinaire celle des Homo sapiens la
nôtre ces enfants traversent les mers et
les montagnes sadapte à tous les
climats plusieurs fois il perdent tout
mais trou toujours le moyen de survivre
et d'aller au-delà de leur
limite ils apprivoisent les plantes les
animaux ils construisent des villages et
changent les paysages l'homme devient la
plus puissante créature du monde animal
il se lanc à la conquête de l'imaginaire
découvre l'art la magie et les
rêves nous sommes leurs enfants leur
savoir s'est transmis sur plus de 50000
générations pour arriver jusqu'à
nous quelle est leur véritable
histoire comment peup la terre comment
ont-ils fait pour que nous soyons là
aujourd'hui voici l'histoire de la
fabuleuse ascension de notre grande
famille celle des Homo
[Musique]
sapiens
comment débute cette histoire comment
notre espèce est-elle apparue d'où
vient-elle rappelez-vous il y a 8
millions d'années la planète se
refroidit soudainement l'eau est aspirée
par lesépaule une immense calotte de
glace forme en Europe et en Asie au nord
la vie commence à s'acclimater au
froid sous les tropiques la nature
assoifffé cherche désespérément un peu
d'humidité en Afrique les grands singes
voient leur forêt disparaître deux
d'entre eux aurorin et T s'adaptent à la
savane et invent une nouvelle façon de
se déplacer ils se mettent
debout il y a 4 millions d'années en
donnant naissance à de nouvelles espèces
mieux adapté les
australopythèques Luc ses congénère se
mettent en marche ils survivent en se
nourrissant de végétaux de plus en plus
dur et coriass puis tomb à leur tour
victime de leur
fragilité et des
prédateurs alors arrive Homo habilis
l'homme habile le premier véritable
représentant du genre humain il invente
l'outil com agir sur le monde et à le
parcourir son évolution le change en
homoctus l'homme dressé le découvreur du
feu le pouvoir de l'homme fait un bon
immense dans le règne animal
ctus se lance à la conquête du monde il
sort d'Afrique entre en Asie et en
Europe quelques dizaines de milliers
d'hommes et de femmes dispersé en petit
groupe qui prépare sans le savoir
l'arrivée de notre
espèce
imaginez nous sommes il y a 400000 ans
au cœur du continent
africain homoctus marche parfois jusqu'à
50 km par jour pour
survivre il chasse de petits animaux des
des racines pour lui et
Lesens
Chem au mieux il vit jusquà 25 ou 30
ans la disparition d'un des leur
toujours vécu comme une
souffranceus SA rien du mystère de la
mortù est parti le souffle pourquoi ne
bougeil
plus toujours derrière le danger qui
menace il faut marcher mourir c'est la
[Musique]
loi la dépouille est abandonné aux
animaux on se rappellera encore quelques
temps de l'être aimé puis le souvenir
s'évanouira quandctus s'installe pour la
nuit il commence par construire des
abris pour se protéger pu il fait un feu
pour écarter les
prédateurs il aussi faire toutes sortes
d'ou mais tout cela ne compte pas pour
la femme qui porte l'enfant voilà des
jours qu'elle ne mange que des racines
la femme a besoin de force pour celui
qui bouge en
elle ne veut plus de ses
racines le chef éctus c'est très bien
qu'il n'a pas réussi à trouver de gibi
très bien quees racines sont cal pas
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour lui
faire remarquer
ctus est curieux et toujours à la fu de
la moindre
nouveauté le chef a déjà entendu ce
bruit mais aujourd'hui ce son qui
résonne lui
plaît mais soudain ça
ça ne risonne
plus ça y est si on colle son oreille
c'est beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
mieux homctus et chasseur au petit matin
le chef et son frère sont partis sur les
traces prometteuses d'une qui marche sur
deux
pattes
mais la trouvé ne suffit pas à la course
elle est beaucoup trop rapide alors on
organise un
stratagème chacun son rôle un qui rabat
l'autre qui
attend des termites Jaun les jaunes lui
il ne peut pas
résister le chef connaî bien le
caractère de celle qui marche sur de
pattes avec ses ufs c'est une
maniaque connait tous un par un et s'il
en manque ne serait qu'un seul c'est la
[Musique]
crise la chasse est lancée le piège va
se refermer sur
l'animal mais que fait le
frère si elle le rattrape c'est la mort
c'est PES sont coupand comme des
silex son bec lui pique la peau comme
une pointe de
lance le frère trouve toujours unyen
pour tout gâcher faire
confiance mais l'animal ne peut plus
fuir c'est une bonne
chose ce jour est un bon jour pour
rectus
[Musique]
ctus commence par manger l'estomac riche
en végétaux puis il découpe l'animal
pour le transporter dans ses
campements les images de la capture sont
encore dans la tête du chef
la bête est tombée dans le trou et tout
est devenu facile il y a là une idée
mais les mouches piqueent et l'empêche
de
réfléchir le corps d' rectus est de
moins en moins volu sa peau nu est
constamment soumise aux agressions des
insectes surtout les endroits
sensibles à cet endroit le frère n'est
pas piqué par les mouches c'est la peau
de
l'animal
avec la peau les mouches ne pi
plus peut-être comme
celausent
l'AB le partage de la viande est soumis
à la place que chacun occupe dans la
hiérarchie du groupe les chasseurs sont
serv les premiers puis vienent les
femelles préfér auqu on réserve un
morceau de
choixaintenant son
GI fierté de chef et de
protecteur mais le pouvoir n'est jamais
acquis on tourne le dos et quelqu'un est
prêt à vous prendre la
place sa pe il oublié sa
pe c'est sa pe c'est sa place il est le
chef il y a des choses qu'on partage pas
comme la femme qui porte l'enfant comme
la souffrance ou
[Musique]
l'espoir de toutes les images qui rempl
sa tête est sor C d'un trou le chef a
décidé d'en creuser un là où les anim
viennent boire pour qu'il tombe dedans
comme C de
P mais de creuser la Bou don une nelle
appar
il ne reconnaî plus son
frère le rire est certainement apparu à
cette époque un comportement qui aura de
l'avenir peut-être les premiers rir de
l'humanité mais aussi la découverte du
beau grâce à une trouvaille
d'importance une pierre différente des
autres il la trouve belle alors la
pierre devient autre chose une parure
qui fait plaisir à
regarder sur lui qu'est-ce que ça donne
il n'est pas beau comme
ça beau et
différent maintenant c'est sa pierre
c'est son signe le signe du
chef chef voudrait que celle qui porte
l'enfant regarde la
pierre ce n'est pas le moment la douleur
est montée dans le ventre de la femme la
femme veut être seule pour ce moment où
l'enfant tombera de son ventre elle sait
ce qu'elle doit faire sans l'avoir
[Musique]
appris le chef est plein d'espoir le
piège la peau qui protège la
pierre mais
l'enfant va-t-il
arriver une fois sur deux il vient sans
le souffle comme ceux qui tombe sur le
chemin parfois même les douleurs se
terminent par la mort de la
femme la vie
[Musique]
viendra-t-elle il est
vivant c'est une petite fille
elle a une drôle de tête avec son front
tout droit et sa peau sans poil elle a
l'air si fragile et
[Musique]
vulnérable le chef ne veut pas que le
froid prenne son
souffle il sait maintenant sa peau n'est
plus pour lui sa peau est pour
[Musique]
l'enfant
sans le savoir ils viennent de donner
naissance à une nouvelle espèce d'homme
une espèce qui va bientôt les
remplacerctus S peut-être qu'il a fait
son temps et que l'avenir est là entre
ses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bras
Homo sapiens arrive il va changer la vie
des hommes et conquérir le
monde l'évolution d' rectus en sapience
s faite sur des centaines de génération
petit à petit son corps devient plus
élancé son front se redresse son cerveau
devient plus vaste plus
complexe sapience sort d'Afrique explore
le MoyenOrient
il commence à s'habiller développe son
sens esthétique et ses outils sa pensée
et son imagination vont faire de lui un
autre
homme nous sommes à moins 100000
ans les orages de chaleur sont les pires
ils tuent à chacun de leurs
[Musique]
passage
mais d' vient cette lumière qui aveugle
qui cche cette colère qui TR
CR un d'entre nous va trouver une répon
grand mystère de la
[Musique]
mortpp le JEE depuis qu'il s
chasséè mère petite
sur
le clan avait marché depuis laavenue du
jour le vent sétait levé soudainement et
le ciel Séta à cracher du
Fe le chef avait cherché un refuge mais
rien et sétait serr les un contre les
autres en attend que pass la fur de la
[Musique]
nature coup sans prévenir sa mère l'a
suivi pour la
protéger à ce moment que la tragédie est
entré dans la vie de
ne de la foudre tombé sur la mer une
bête à corne est
apparue V l'animal est parti en laissant
les corps de sa sœur et de la mère sur
le
sol
[Musique]
elle ne bougeit
plus pas protéger ilen vou il fallait
qu'elle bouge qu' se REM
[Musique]
debout trs vitere com
souff
pas
il que T
ét rien à faire LEF V plus vite vou
rester là il vou attendre qu'elle se
réveille comme si cétait
possible le chef ne comprenit
pas pasandon
alors on s'est arrêté là au début
c'était juste pour une
[Musique]
nuit SAP nomade avec ses il fait
maintenant des abris son langage s
perfectionné il a des mots pour parler
des choses abstraites comme du temps
derrière soi et du devant
son cerveau a plus de mémoire il est
capable de plus d'association son
imagination s'en trouve augmentée et il
est probable que ses rêves deviennent
plus impressionnant dans son sommeil
SAPI croit qu'il voyage dans un autre
monde un monde parallèle situé derrière
les
yeux le clan Dorma encore quand une bête
à grande corne est venue boire à la
rivière
le corps d'un animal de cette taille
c'était de la viande pour tout le
clan pour ne cela ne faisait aucun doute
c'était la même bête à corne celle qui
était venue la veille dans la grande
lumière cette foisl le chef n'a pas été
trop maladroit
elle était blessée à mort le chef était
fier le clan aurait des semaines de
nourriture grâce à lui mais ce n'est pas
la viande qui occup les pensées de dans
le souffle de l'animal qui s'enfuyait il
entendait gémir la voix de sa sœur
au moment où la bête perdait la vie
l'inexplicable est
[Musique]
arrivé le souffle de l'animal avait
disparu et celui de sa sœur était revenu
comment était-ce
possible na
respir elle retrouva la
[Musique]
vie c'est que Na est revenu parmi nous
et tout le monde
réjou é préoccupé il voulait comprendre
ce qui s'était
passé
l'animal avait-il donné son souffle à sa
sœur la mort de l'animal avait-elle
permis de redonner la vie à Naoki
c'était un grand
mystère le chef aurait voulu qu'on le
félicite pour sa prise mais tout le clan
était fasciné par le miracle de
[Musique]
nek
Neka avait un nouvel
espoir peut-être restait-il dans la peau
de la bête un peu du souffle de l'animal
pour le donner à sa
mère au début tout le monde s'est dit
que Nea avait perdu la raison mais il
suivait une idée fixe la bête à corne
pouvait redonner vie à sa
mère
on espéit aussi que la mère reviendrait
mais le comportement de ne nous échapp
il ne mangea pas il près du cor en
attendant un
signe le SIG est venu du ciel comme
toujours les Charon sont arrivés pour
prendre le
cadavre C
auss la ch de mère aucun souffle pour
revenir
c'est peut-être ce jour-l comomos
sapiens a inventé la première
[Musique]
sépulture pour protéger le corps du
défun probablement aussi pour se
protéger de la vision de ce corps qui
pourrit car même sans les vautours le
corps disparaissait petit à
[Musique]
petit
n
n le chef voulait que Neka mange et il
s'est personnellement déplacé pour lui
offrir un morceau de choix ce qu'il ne
fait jamais en fait il voulait que Neka
lui donne le secret de sa magie il
voulait comprendre comment Neka avait
redonné vie à
Naoki mais il n'était pas au bout de ses
surprises
lui disait que sa mère vivait dans un
autre monde et qu'elle devait
manger mais le jeune a donné sa viande
pour la
mer était trop n'ait plus besoin de
nourriture était
morte
certains d'entre nous ont commencé à y
croire c'était le monde dans lequel on
allait en dormant on y croisait nos
mort c'était le pays des
songes quelques jours plus tard trois
d'entre nous ont décidé de quitter le
clan nous étions nombreux et les
conflits éclatent trop souvent il voulit
trouver un autre clan et un autre
chef celui-là il ne le supportait plus
[Musique]
avant de partir il voulait entendre
encore nec raconter les images qu'il
voyait derrière ses
[Musique]
yeux il voulait écouter le récit
extraordinaire de la mère de Neka pour
ne pas l'oublier pour l'emporter avec
eux
[Musique]
VO l'autre monde celui où les morts all
quand le souffle les quitt il voyait sa
mère avec la bête grand corne et sa mère
le regardait comme pour lui dire que
tout allait bien nait plus faim qu'elle
n'avait plus
[Musique]
froid derrière ses yeux il y avait une
lueur qui disait que la vie continuait
ailleurs une vie après la mort et cela
change
tout ces croyances sont sans toutoutes
les prémisses de la pensée religieuse
une extraordinaire composition de
l'imaginaire qui dotera sapience d'une
force phénoménale la foi l'idée
d'éternité va se répandre chez tous les
peuples et apaiser l'angoisse de la mort
l'homme peut maintenant s'engager
au-delà des limites de sa propre
existence le temps des croyances
chamaniques est arrivé le monde des
esprits côoi maintenant celui des
vivants nous sommes entre Mo- 100000 et
Mo- 50000 ans sapience explore presque
tous les territoires de la planète
certains vont vers l'Asie d'autres vers
l'Europe pourquoi ce risque dans un
monde inconnu suiv les migration du
gibier de la nature beaucoup cro au
pouvoir du soleil et de la
lune il y a 500 ans le premier groupe
d'Homo sapiens arrive au sud de l'Europe
ce Clane sa vie au soleil sa disparition
en plein jour les
terrifie
[Musique]
une femme entre en trans pour lutter
contre les dévoreurs de
[Musique]
lumière il revient le soleil
revient
la femme qui les guide chaman elle
s'appelle nat et né de TR
[Applaudissements]
sœurs pour le soleil assombr est un
mauvais signe les soleils doivent être
for pour que vive le clan il faut les
suivre derrière les montagnes jusque
dans le pays où ils vont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tousimité deses il devra
renonc
engager dans le voyage le plus périlleux
qu'il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais découvre la terre blanche pour la
première fois mais le pied
brûle c'est comme une peau sur les
choses qui prend la forme de tout ce qui
la
touche
alors pour se protéger du froid sa
pience invente la
chaussure rien narrête la détermination
de la chaman il faut continuer à monter
et le PE se à piquer le membr se m àel
il voudrait redescendre mais personne n'
défieram
p le matriar est largement répondu les
femmes ont l'autorité es sont responsa
de l'avenir du clan les
hommes le vient de perdre son oreille il
n
douleur que faire de son oreille gelée
comment la rattacher le MU attend la vie
de la femme
chamane il n'y a rien à faire sauf
peut-être la
manger non le mie préfère la manger
lui-même après tout c'est son
oreille un soleil nouveau s levé ce
matin mais ces premiers rayons
n'apportent ni chaleur ni nourriture en
allant vers les terres froides la peau
de sapens s éclairci afin de mieux
capter les rayons UltraViolet et de
favoriser la synthèse de vitamines
essentiell ils sont adapt à une plus
faible exposition soleil mais pas à la
haute
montagne durant son sommeil la première
S de est partie dans l'autre monde son
corps froid est devenu dur comme du
bois les croyances de sapiens sont aussi
nombreuses que les mystères de la
nature pour ce clan il n'y a pas de
sépulture ils offrent le corps des
défunts à la lumière elle les mange et
les emmène vers le pays de l'autre vie
nata accompagne les morts pour les aider
à trouver le chemin
un jour elle retrouvera sa sœur dans le
monde des
[Musique]
soleils il continu d'avancer il n'ont
mangé que de la neige depuis 3 jours NAT
le a promis qu'au bout du chemin la nuit
n'existait plus et cela leur donne du
courage mais le courage ne nourrit pas
les plus
faibles
chez sapiens tout le monde n'a pas droit
à une cérémonie certains sont abandonnés
sans r
funéraire c'est la peine qui prouve sa s
elle ressent la souffrance de son clan
mais ils ne peuvent pas
s'arrêter comment ont-ils fait pour
résister est-ce leurs habits en peau ou
la graisse animale dont ils senduisaient
le corps la conquête des terres vierg se
payent au prix
fort sur le chemin sapience laisse
beaucoup des siens mais tous ces
territoires exploré profiteront aux
prochaines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
générations
ils sont désormais moins que les doigts
d'une
main alors que leurs force les abandonne
l'espoir
Rena trois formes recouvertes de neige
certainement des
animaux de la nourriture pour retrouver
des forces et aller jusqu'au bout du
voyage ils sont
sauvés
des
pierres plusieurs
pierres que font ces pierres sur des
animaux une aile d'oiseau mais elle n'a
pas de
chair d'autres hommes sont venus avant
mais qui sont-ils et d'où
viennent-ils pourquoi ces corps
emprisonnés sous la pierre leur crâne ne
ressemblent pas au
autre nata est perdu le pays des soleils
n'est pas ici il n'y a rien à manger ils
sont
condamnés dans cet enfer personne ne
peut
survivre personne sauf peut-être un être
exceptionnel
ou dans cette Europe froide et hostile
une autre espèce humaine s'est
parfaitement adaptée au milieu l'homme
de
Néandertal nata et les siens viennent
d'entrer dans leur
territoire ils ont ouvert les tombes de
leurs
ancêtres Néandertal est lui aussi un
descendant
d'homoerectus son ancêtre est arrivé en
Europe il y a 2 millions d'années il
s'est adapté au froid qui s'installait
et est devenu une force de la nature le
chef néand dertal a décidé de ramener
les étrangers au
camp quand nata ouvre les yeux
elle ne sait plus si elle est dans le
monde des vivants quels sont ces gens
qui ne sont pas tout à fait
désolés
sans jamais avoir été en contact avec sa
pience Néandertal aussi fait de son côté
de nombreuses découvertes le monde
invisible les croyances la musique le
feu il vit dans des cavernes et enterre
ses
morts nata et les siens ont été
recueillis par le clan de la
lune leur chef veut savoir qui a osé
déterrer ses
ancêtres le visage de Natal intrigue qui
sont ces êtres au front plat il faut
qu'il reviennent à la vie celui qui mène
le clan de la lune veut tout savoir sur
eux
[Musique]
oh la chamane reprend parfois conscience
mais ce qu'elle découvre est si étrange
et différent de tout ce qu'elle
sait
que font-il de son
compagnon ils ne peuvent pas faire ça il
doit rester avec elle elle a besoin de
lui différence de culture de langage de
mode de vie pour ces sapiens les cultes
de Néandertal sont des sacrilèges
pourtant sa culture n'est pas moins
riche moins
belle le lendemain l'odeur de la viande
grillée réveille s la est plus forte que
tout depuis la neige elles ont tout
oublié sont qui les
iciu les images de ces hommes Gron
reviennent peupler les pensées de
Nat
qui sont ces
gensvenir de son
pé pas un
rve souvent maintenant de l'endroit où
ils ont enfermé son compagnon
ne sait pas ce une
[Musique]
tombe
il l'ont caché comme un gibier qu'on
garde pour plus tard comme les
squelettes dans la
neige sam est mort
[Musique]
elle doit le rendre à la lumière pour
que son esprit puisse partir avec le
vent des
montagnes pour survivre pendant la
froidure de l'hiver nandertal se nourrit
principalement de viande il est le plus
grand chasseur de la
planète r la caverne une surprise le
chef
[Musique]
ve il
aut entré dans la terre
quelle est cette voix
étrangei qui
[Musique]
appelle son mort était là et la femme
criait le chef né ne comprend pas la TR
de
mais il est surpris par les mouvements
de son
corps nata et sa sœur resteront avec le
clan de la
[Musique]
Lune sans le savoir ces apiens auront
découvert un nouveau continent l'Europe
cette traversée des Alpes a ouvert la
route et d'autres suivront bientôt les
traces de ces
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pionniers cette rencontre n'est que la
première d'autres suivront dans quelques
millénaires sapiens et Néandertal
vivront ensemble une aventure
exceptionnelle celle de la grande
chasse au même moment de l'autre côté de
la planète Homo sapiens découvre l'Asie
avec la glaciation le niveau des océans
est alors 120 m plus bas qu'aujourd'hui
les îles d'Asie du Sud-Est sont relié
entre elles Homo sapiens va pousser son
voyage jusqu'à la limite des
terres au cours de ces migrations sa
pien a changé d'apparence les climats et
les environnements ont modifié la forme
de ses yeux de son nez et la couleur de
sa peau il a aussi découvert un nouveau
et fabuleux moyen pour se déplacer
la
navigation depuis des générations le
Clan de la Rivière a fait des fleuves le
centre de sa vie pour eux l'eau est
sacrée elle est la direction qu'il
suivent et les protège contre les
dangers voilà des mois qu' descendent
sec cours d'eau ils ont traversé la
péninsule indonésienne sans avoir croisé
un seul
clan pourtant un autre humain est déjà
là depuis longtemps et il observe chacun
de leurs
[Musique]
gestes
caini
descendantomctus il y a presque millions
d'années ilolu en plusieurs sousespèce
qui peup l'Asie h de pin h de Java de
Flor chacun d'entre est adap
sonie
le jeune est le seul à l'avoir vu et
personne ne veut le
croire le Clan de la Rivière ne s'arrête
jamais de naviger il sens de l'eau se
laiss porter par les courants de cette
veine qui devient chaque jour plus
[Musique]
large il y a 60000 ans le Clan de la
Rivière arrive au bout des terres d'Asie
et découvreéan pafi
pourière
dont on voit pas l'autre
[Musique]
rive il n jamais vu ça ils sont fascinés
par ces vagues immes par ce son qui fait
trembler leur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
corps le chef est déterminé à trouver le
chemin jusau bout de
l'eau partager le clan en deux groupes
il part avec son chaman et sa famille et
reviendra ensuite chercher le reste du
clan Homo sapiens ne sait pas encore
qu'en face de lui des milliers de
kilomètres d'eau profonde sont prêt à
l'engloutir
emporté par sa foi ce petit groupe
d'hommes et de femmes s'élance à la
conquête d'un océan dont ils ignorent
toute la
monstruosité ceux qui reste ont installé
leur campement trois femmes et un enfant
se guerer de SERP le plus habile pêcheur
du clan depuis le installation l'homme
curieux est venu plusieurs fois toujours
le même il fait toujours la même
[Musique]
chose de ser rencontrer il sait qu'il
faut toujours apprivoiser ceux qui
viennent d'ailleurs pour éviter qu'il ne
devienne mauvais ou
[Musique]
dangereux l'homme repart toujours son
Attitud
estcpréhible cette foisci de serpent a
décidé d'agir
différemment il saitcun homme n'a réussi
à le prendre des
vitesses dans cette jungle asiatique il
s lire tous les signaux décrypter les
cris des animaux et localiser n'importe
quelle créature à
distance il est là tout près que
[Musique]
veut-il
il de serpent fait Captur comme un
buffleugle de SERP est tombé dans les
griffun gé de
lactus sont réité
ch
et mangeable même les humains dans
certaines
circonstanceses homoctusont capturé
comme ils auraient pris un bel oiseau
pour l'instant il regardent ses plumes
et ses couleurs il l'invite à partager
leur repas mais de quel sang
s'agitil
vont-il après cela le tuer et le manger
à son four
œil de serpent doit rester
calme ce qui naviguent vers l'autre rive
ont vite été emportés les vents et les
courants les éloignent de toute
terre quand il se réveille ce matin-là
il n'y a plus aucune rive ni d'un côté
ni de l'autre
il n'y a plus un seul oiseau dans le
[Musique]
ciel le monde a disparu le fleu géant a
tout
[Musique]
recouvert il DVE lentement vers
l'Antartique
il de SERP vivant il sont
sa de serpent excité lariosité de
chasseurs Ilir plus les sec de
hom
sur le pouvoir de le coquillage et de
les
hameç le chef du clan n'est toujours pas
revenu que faire s'il ne rentre
[Musique]
pas affaibli par le manque d'eau le
chaman vient de mourir ses croyances se
sont
effondré souvent face à la violence de
la nature Homo sapiens doute de la
raison de son
existence
ce qui March sur l'eau commencent à
échanger leur savoir avec ceux de la
forêt l'art de la paru les techniques de
pêche la fabrication des outils des
habits des liens se forment entre ces
deux populationsant éloign
génétiquement il est probable que
partout sur le continent asiatique SAPI
etctus so mélang pour former em la
grande famille des peuples
d'Asie des centes de
kilomètrig force déshydraté et brûlé par
le
soleil la
terre l'autre côté du grand
fleuve le monde est revenu il est
remonté des
[Musique]
profondeurs
ils ont navigué pendant des jours et des
jours grâce au courant à leur
inconscience et leur audace ils
arrivaient puiser sur une terre que
l'homme n'a jamais
[Musique]
foulé peut-être croi-il avoir atteint le
monde secret de leur
[Musique]
rêve il y a 60000 ans
Homo sapiens découvre
l'Australie une terre immense détachée
du reste du monde depuis des millions
d'années le berceau d'espèces animales
et végétales
[Musique]
unique ils navigueront encore de
nombreuses fois sur l'océan sans jamais
retrouver leur chemin ils seront à
l'origine d'une autre grande famille
humaine un peuple d'extraordinair
navigateurs la famille du
dans le reste de l'Asie l'immigration
continue Homo sapiens traverse la Chine
et passe en Amérique à pied par le
détroit de Bering il découvre un autre
nouveau continent vaste et riche en gibi
il pousse son chemin jusquen Amérique du
Sud pendant ce temps SAP entre en Europe
par VAG successive il sadapte froid et
laere dans nous sommes à Mo 40000
ans l'hiver européen est terrible balayé
par les vents glacial la seule
nourriture pour l'homme est la viande
mais les troupau ne sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous parfois même ils
disparaissent et la famine s'installe sa
déplace s campement toujours plus loin
en espérant trouver du
gibier il vit dans des tipis fait de PE
et de branch qu'il plante au sommet des
collines pour guetter le moindre
animal fa
pas dans ces moments de carence les
femmes n'ont même plus de lait pour
nourrir leurs enfants et ils Meur les
uns après les
autres le chef du clan des reines n'a
trouvé qu'un malheureux lapin mort de
froid ce n'est pas avec ça qu'il va
nourrir ces deux femmes et son clan le
clan des reines est en train de devenir
le clan du
silence
àinçablement akia le chef parcourt les
alentours à la recherche du m dans
LESISS du moindre cri
animal même la chair dure et puante de
l'oiseau noir est une au avec sa
nouvelle arme le propulseur il ne rate
jamais une cible à cette
[Musique]
distance
il veut savoir qui elle est pourquoi
elle se trouve là la femme de comprend
pas
elle ve son
coler
visage bus
desux comme si
éetteem fatie du peuple
N souffre du manque de gibier elle
semble apprécier les coquillages du
collier de sapiens elle n'a jamais vu
ça mais il est pris tout entier par son
désir de la toucher de la
sentir il ve
[Musique]
SAR jamais une femme ne lui a résisté de
la sorte
lu le chef du clan
des
au petit matin des cris d'animaux
retenti près du campement des cris comme
il jamais entendu et là devant eux
descendant du Nord des animaux énor
couvert de long poil et arm de d
imm ce sont des long le chaman le sa il
en avait beaucoup autrefis des grands
troupeau il av
disparette
et comment faire pour les
tuer le vieux fou est prêt à les
affronter mais cela ne rassure pas le
chef le chaman trouve toujours les mots
il fera venir l'esprit des ancêtres et
donner la force au
chasseur vain le
Cham les MAM occupent la terre depuis
des millions d'années pour pour les
hommes la nouvelle glaciation est un
fléo unassablement ces grands animaux
parcourent des distances énormes pour
trouver les 200 kg de fourrage dont ils
ont besoin chaque
jour le chaman reste au sommet de la
montagne il parle au gens
invisibles esprit de nos ancêtres don
courage et force à nos chasseurs tu pour
nous ces
géants
tué le re le le cochon mais jamais il
s'er pare
[Musique]
puissance monstes il sont rien la peur
Lesur deette
VI le Bou
jamb
[Musique]
ils sont trop rapides les longs nez se
méfient de l'homme il le
[Musique]
fuit il le fuit jusqu'au moment où il se
retrouve bloqué contraint de se
retourner et sans autre solution que de
l'affronter et là leur peur les rend
encore plus
dangereux sauf l'un d'entre eux plus
jeune et effrayé par les crises humains
il ne veut pas revenir sur ses
pas maintenant le combat devient
inévitable ah
[Musique]
ils ont perdu la chasse et l'un d'entre
eux a perdu le souffle mais il y a
encore un espoir là-bas un groupe de
Néandertal ils sont aussi venus pour
tuer ils ont un avantage sur ceux du
clan des reennes ils connaissent le
pouvoir du feu sur les longs
nez de l'autre côté la femme Néandertal
est fris le dernier mammouth il doit
rebrouss s chemins il y a encore une
chance une
dernière
[Musique]
leurs Saget ne sont rien contre la
dureté de la peau de l'animal mais il
n'ont pas le
[Musique]
choix le jeune Mamou fonce maintenant
vers la sortie mais n est
là
si Néandertal sait qu'il peut affronter
la pête quand elle est isolée il sait
aussi que ça ne suffit pas il faut lui
couper toute
retraite nertal est le plus grand des
chasseurs mais un mal mystérieux ronge
son
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
corps le long nez est bloqué
pour la première fois SAPI nal se
retrouvent un autour d'une même proie
poussé par le même instin de survie
ensemblees hommes etes femmes fer
retraite au
[Applaudissements]
gé il faut l'empêcher de bouger et
restreindre son espace au minimum la
femme n n plus en compétition avec
l'homme
[Musique]
SAPI est
il est à la merci des LAN il faut
frapper dans les endroits les plus
vulnérables l'INE et l'anus où la peau
est moins
[Musique]
épaisse
le chaman remerciera les ancêtres
jusqu'à la nuit grâce à eux le clan des
reennes vient d'inventer une nouvelle
façon de chasser la grande chasse
organisée et cette nouveauté va avoir
des conséquences considérables sur la
vie des hommes
avec la viande du mammouth les deux
clans ont de la nourriture comme ils
n'en ont jamais eu ils peuvent rester
des mois sans chasser pour la première
fois les hommes ont du temps devant du
temps libre pour penser expérimenter et
faire des choses apparemment
[Rires]
inutiles
NAND et sapens se retrouvent
ensembleutour d'un repas avec de
nouveaux
sentiments de l'entraide de la
solidarité et aussi de
[Musique]
l'tirance la femme nét LEF du clan des
re pour
mais a déj de compag et Ren
elles sont d'accord désormais elles
vivront
ensemble de ont beaucoup à apprendre
l'un de l'autre et cela passera par un
long apprentissage du langage petit à
petit mot par
mot
la découverte de la coopération pour les
grandes chasses prépare un mouvement
inéluctable de rapprochement entre les
hommes de différentes origines bientôt
des liens nouveaux vont voir le jour
mariage
alliance les racines de la société
ce soir akia veut prendre celle qui le
rend fort et
heureux quel est ce mal qui fait saigner
son nez la femme n souffre mais il se
plais et ils veulent mieux se
[Musique]
connaître cette alliance ne plaît pas au
chaman il se méfie de la femme
N
cette femme et cet homme appartiennent
tous deux au genre humain mais ils ne
sont pas de la même espèce leur union ne
peut donner de descendance ils sont
génétiquement
[Musique]
différents l'esprit de la femme a volé
celui de son
chef
il faut protéger le clan des reines et
communiquer avec la pensée
d'AK ce soir le feu projette l'ombre du
chapeau du chef sur le
rocher pour le chaman c'est la partie
animale qui est dans le chef et elle
danse sur la
pierre il la
voit il veut garder le souvenir de ce
moment magique alors il en suit les
contours avec du charbon de bois
l'esprit est
làes reste sur la pierre il repris à la
femme il y a 40000 ans la première
représentation symbolique est fixé sur
de la pierre la naissance de l' cette
invention AA bientôt une portée
universelle
[Musique]
quelques années ont passé les de CL on
fait route ensemble mais presque tous
les nal sont Mor du mal qui les affecte
tous il ne sont plus que TR dans la
femme du chef
[Musique]
elle n'en peut plus elle doit rester là
c'est la fin du
[Musique]
voyage aucun enfant n'est venu de son
ventre le clan ne peut s'arrêter l'iver
les talon il faut marcher vers le
[Musique]
sud
le temps
presse celui qui marche devant il doit
se conduire comme tel P avant tout à
l'avenir du clan des
Rees épuisé par les fièvres la femme
veut se reposer et refroidir son corps
dans l'eau
glacée
[Musique]
Néandertal se Meur les humains de cette
espèce vont peu à peu disparaître de la
terre fauché par les maladies par une
réduction des naissances
cela reste encore un
[Musique]
mystère akia ne veut plus entendre les
prières du
[Musique]
chaman peut-être se doute-til de la
fragilité de notre
[Musique]
espèce nandertal disparaî la chasse au
grand mammifère se rép sur toute la
planète le rythme de vie change plus de
temps libre plus de création Homo
sapiens sculpte ses objets fabrique des
parures et décor ses outils une
véritable explosion culturel dans
certains endroits une création humaine
surpuissante va voir le jour l'art
pariétal l'art va devenir un
message nous sommes en France il y a
20000 ans Homo sapiens s dispersé dans
toute
l'Europe parfois il souffr d'isolement
certains clans ne trouvent pas d'autres
populations avec lesquelles se mélanger
ils se reproduisent entre eux sur une de
TR générations inévitablement la
consanguinité frappe leurs enfants les
rend incapable de se reproduire à leur
tour et d'assurer l'avenir du clan voil
des années que le sorcier cherche à
guérir les siens de cette
[Musique]
malédiction mais l'ancêtre qui les guide
reste mu il ne répond
plus
[Musique]
perdu son
pouvoir qu'est-ce qu'un sorcier pas
capable de soigner son
clan se isolé du reste du groupe avec
son fils sur les
bras
autrefois le clan des chasseurs de bison
était prospère il y avait h chasseurs 12
femmes et de nombreux
enfants aujourd'hui il ne sont plus que
ne et un seul enfant mal sil ne trou pas
rapidement une solution le clan
[Musique]
disparaîtra le chef vient de découvrir
un abri pour
l'ER agité comme si ce lieu lui parlait
comme s'il entendait des
[Musique]
voix la caverne est accueillante
spacieuse proche de l'eau et abrité du
vent elle a la forme d'un
crâne des feux ont été allumés ici et là
des gens dormis des gens
ut on v
i à
prés le premier à repérer le
passage mal il cherch toujours à se
cacher pour être en dehors du
monde une
présence
qui se cache au fond du ventre de la
caverne des ours lions des
[Musique]
humains la roche répond à sa
VO les grottes sont les meilleurs
endroits pour les rituel
chamani luî
propice
mais ils sont autre chose là juste à
côté de
lui des signes fait par la main de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'homme les premiers ornements rupest il
figurent des STR des cercles des
spirales ces formes sont les visions
d'un chaman dans le premier stade de sa
TR
hucinatoire ils étai
là v cette roche que s'estil passé ici
ontil voulu laisser un
[Musique]
message prendre les forces caché dans
les racines les insectes et les
molusques il en fait des couleurs pour
sa peinture et des potions pour soigner
grâce à eux il pourra retrouver l'esprit
garé de son
fils à côté de lui dans le monde du
[Musique]
visible cette Limas donne la vision elle
permet d'atteindre les profondeurs de
l'âme et de voyager dans
l'invisible là où se cache l'esprit de
son
[Musique]
enfant
son ancêtre sorcier lui avait tout
appris en retournant à la nature il y a
bien longtemps il était devenu bison
mais son esprit GUID
toujours fait appel à la force de
l'animal il lui demande de l'aider pour
guérir son
enfant
[Musique]
cette Lim s'chit rapidement elle est
spécialement
efficace l'esprit malade de l'enfant
résiste il ne veut pas se laisser
attraper il fuit atka le suit pas à pas
il ne le laissera pas s'échapper
audessus de la Trance le clan s'est
installé pour le repas ce qu'ils
attendent depuis des années est en train
d'arriver des hommes et des femmes d'un
autre clan il ne parl pas la même langue
il faut accueillir ceux qui viennent
d'ailleurs la chance est avec
nous ils ne veulent pas d'un autre clan
ici ils ne veulent pas
partager alors que les bras vont frappé
l'esprit du bison s du
[Rires]
[Musique]
cor cette femme porte les signes des
sorciers
elle a tout de suite entendu les appels
d' dans les profondeurs du crâne en
[Musique]
pierre le sorcier n'est plus son ne lui
appartient plus mouvements sont de
l'animal la sorcière l'a compris elle
entre dans sa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tr
la M trace les contours d'une nouvelle
image devant les yeux des étrangers les
hommes des deux clans sont pris par le
spectacle il C de se battre et attend la
[Musique]
suite l'image pr une forme qu'il
connaiss leelle une émotion qu'ils ont
déjà vécu il regard il ressentent la
même chose et cela leur va droit dans le
[Musique]
cœur tout bouge et se transforme est-ce
grâce à la lueur des flammes ou à la
danse du
sorcier il voi tous l'esprit de l'animal
il avance il marche ils l'entendent même
ils vivent ensemble l'intérieur de l'âme
[Musique]
humaine
la peinture des cavernes devient un
langage qui va permettre à tous les Homo
sapiens de se comprendre et de
s'accepter
elle sera un message universel qui
touche le cœur des hommes et les rend
tous
[Musique]
solidaires
ils s'entraident ils échangent leur
savoir ils trouvent une meilleure façon
de se protéger des vent glacial il
prépare ensemble l'arrivée de
l'hiver n' pas pu retrouver l'esprit
perdu de l'enfant pas
encore les de sorcierschangent le secret
sur les plantes médicinales à de il
deviennent de fois plus
il commence la grande collecte des
mystères de la nature de ce savoir
immense naîtra un jour la médecine
[Musique]
entre Mo 30000 et 20000 ans des
chefdœuvres apparaissent presque sur
toute la planète à des milliers de
kilomètres les uns des autres comme si
tous les Homo sapiens sétaient donner le
mot partout l'art rassemble des petits
groupes d'hommes et les fédè en
communauté plus vaste
bientôt des populations immenses vont
s'unifier pour devenir des
peuples mais soudain il y a 12000 ans la
température monte c'est le début d'un
changement climatique majeur les de
tiers de la glace retenue au pôle
fondent le niveau des océans remonte de
m continents prennent peu à peu les
formes qu'on leur connaît aujourd'hui
une époque grandiose de la vie des
hommes s'achève mais une nouvelle
commence presque partout la température
devient clémente l'eau abondante et la
terre généreuse sapience découvre des
régions tellement riches en gibier en
plantes comestibles qu'il s'arrête de
marcher il construit des villages de
Pierr fait pour durer c'est pour
beaucoup la fin d'une vie de nomade
toujours avec la
sédentarisation tout va
[Musique]
changer nous sommes en Mésopotamie il y
a 10000
[Musique]
ans écoute mon
histoire
vire éta JEE alors les NES ne connaiss
pas encore tout ce que l'on sa
[Musique]
aujourd'hui n é un homme apprécié de
tous particulièrement de ma mère ilr
pour la voir quand il R de la
chasse toujours des
d'oiseau
depuis quelqu temps la vie éta devenue
moins dure pour les hommes et les femmes
il commenç à prendre du temps pour être
heureux
ensemble amouruse
de amour de ma
[Rires]
[Musique]
mère il ne cach pas le affection à la
vie de
tous
et surt le chef du
village la faisait à peine de lunes
é ét heureux et
[Musique]
insouci jour elle avait eu un
pressentiment en ce tempslà nous devions
aller loin dans la montagne pour cuillir
les blés sauvages qui pouss c'était la
fin de l'été et l'on devait ramasser le
plus de grains possible pour passer
l'hiver sans
[Musique]
manquer N saait saison le faucon pondait
ses œufs ma mère aimait tellement les
œufs cet homme il y a 10000 ans connaî
parfaitement la nature elle ne le fait
plus souffrir elle est pleine de
surprises merveilleuses et il commence à
jouer avec
[Musique]
elle
elle ne l'a pas vu partir
cro qu'il est en train de lui jouer un
[Musique]
tour puis elle souvient de son
pressentiment hom sapiens joue avec la
nature
mais parfois quand il va trop loin la
nature refuse de
[Musique]
jouer la montagne avalé le corps de
N ma mère le
[Musique]
cherche jusqu'au moment où ils entendent
le cri du
loup ils prennent peur pour
n rester ensemble si les lou ét
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nombreux une
plainte H qui
s que n est là tout proche
d'elle
[Musique]
ce n'est pas Néné mais le plus étrange
spectacle qui lui est été donné de voir
un petitme avec une louve des montagnes
le plus féroce des
carnaers les loups étaient à côté de
nous depuis toujours quand nos enfants
se perdai dans la forêt les lou les
dévor nous n'imion pas les Lou notre
chef il en avait tué plus
[Musique]
d'un mais il n'a pas le temps de
s'occuper de celuilà il entend à son
tour les GISS de
l'enfant l'enfant est
faroucheement abandonné par un autre
clan
[Musique]
ma mère veut le réconforter mais il
refuse le chef en a vu d'aut ce n'est
pas cet enfant qui va changer l'ordre
des choses
occupé par le sort de l'enfant il cesse
de chercher n de toute manière s'il
était par là il le
répondra vit ici dans de petites hutes
de Pierr rassemblé autour d'un grenier
commun le premier village les premières
maisons ma mère a pris l'enfant avec
elle et l' installé sur la couche de
Néné mais l'enfant ne veut pas
[Musique]
dormir il écoute la
montagne
elle ne pouvait pas croire que la louve
était la mère de
l'enfant sa mère
animal on avait encore jamais vu
ça ma mère avait beaucoup d'amour à
donn peut-être trop pour elle tout
seule
j'étais cet enfant sauvage je ne me
sentais pas homme je me prenais pour un
Lou
un mère animal m'avait
recueilli dans ce premier village
homopiens partage les tâches chacun
travaille pour la communauté les PO
servent maintenant de récipient les
pierres chauffé au feu font bouillir les
marmites les femmes pensent aux
hommes il n a plus vraiment de clan mais
plusieurs familles et chaque famille a
son foyer
on se rend service on se rend visite la
polygamie a tendance à disparaître la
famille se resserre autour du couple un
homme et une femme leurs enfants et
parfois leurs parents la famille
d'aujourd'hui est en train de naître et
celle dont rêv ma mère vient de
disparaître aucune trace de N personne
l'a Vune l'A
entendure besoin d'aimer besoin de
donner elle ne pouvait rester seule sans
partager sa
[Musique]
vie je ne voulais personne près de moi
je ne supportais pas qu'on me touche ni
le contact et l'odeur des
[Musique]
habits
je n'accepta que sa
présence mais pas la viande noire de feu
qu'elle voulait me faire
manger pe elle s'attacha à l'enfant
sauvage elle s'attacha à moi j'étais en
train de prendre une place dans son
cœur la place d'un
[Musique]
fils
la louve est revenue un beau jour pour
réclamer son fils
elle m'avait nourri protégé réchauffé
depuis que j'étais à nouveau
[Musique]
né
les hommes n'aiment pas les loups parce
qu'ils ne les connaissent pas jamais ma
mère Lou ne m'aurait fait de mal pourant
les hommes me croyent en danger avec
elle comme le sont tous les enfants avec
tous les
[Musique]
loup
elle a été la première à
comprendre peut-être parce qu'elle
ressentait l'amour de
l'animal parce qu'elle souffrait elle
aussi de l'absence de celui qu'elle
avait
aimé j'avais maintenant deux mères et je
ne savais pas laquelle
[Musique]
choisir
elle a su parler au loup comme un
enfant voilà comment ma mère est devenue
ma mère pour toute la
[Musique]
vie
une année a passé j'ai grandi dans le
monde des hommes la lou près du village
petit à petit elle s'est habitu à la
présence des
hommes une alliance est né entre l'homme
et l'animal et ça a été le début d'une
grande aventure avec les loups mais
aussi avec d'autres animaux
il y a 12000 ans le premier loup rejoint
la communauté des hommes mais il faudra
des générations de loups nés chez les
hommes pour qu'ils deviennent ce que
nous appelons aujourd'hui le
[Musique]
chien grâce à ma mère louve nous avons
fait d'autres
découvertes
un corps mort depuis longtemps j'isis au
milieu des blés
sauvages c'était la dépouille de
[Musique]
Néné il avait disparu le jour où ma mère
m'avait trouvé elle m'avait donné
l'amour qu'elle avait pour lui
[Musique]
cétait son
col ma mère a tout de suite su ce
qu'elle devait en
faire les grain de blé qui ét dans la
BES de N
germ tombé il av
[Musique]
poussé le chef comprit que chaque grain
sétait reproduit une multitude
d'aut cétait
simpne jamais
penséère m'a don le coler de
N j'ai grandi toute ma vie avec jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
ce collier te revient
désormais à toi le fils de mon
fils
portele et transmetsle à ceux qui
viendront après
toi raconte cette histoire à tous les
hommes afin qu'il ne l'oublie
[Musique]
jamais
nous sommes il y a 10000 ans grâce à ces
deux fabuleuses découvertes la vie des
hommes va
basculer la découverte de l'agriculture
se propage alors sur toute la terre en
quelques siècles Homo sapiens s'installe
durablement à proximité de ses cultures
il calque sa vie sur les rythmes des
saisons récoltant chaque année le fruit
de son
[Musique]
travail la domestication du loup est
suivie par celle de nombreux autres
animaux Homo sapiens découvre l'élevage
qui procure une alimentation sûre et
[Musique]
abondante dans de nombreux endroits du
monde des monumentss gigantesques se
dressent vers les cieux en hommage aux
divinité dont sapience se dit le
fils les hommes se multiplient les
villages se construisent les échanges
s'intensifient des groupes de plus en
plus vaste se
constituent bientôt des grandes
civilisations vont voir le
jour la préhistoire est
finie quelle que soit la couleur de
notre peau quelle que soit la forme de
nos yeux les 6 milliards d'êtres humains
qui peuplent notre terre aujourd'hui
descendent tous d'une même famille
elle a vécu dans la nuit des temps et
enfantera des milliers de générations
d'hommes et de femmes jusqu'à
nous leur découverte éclaire toujours
nos vies tel est le ton que nos parents
aussi lointains soit-il nous ont
fait grâce à eux nos enfants iront pe
d'autres
[Musique]
planètes